hi there today we'll look at group
normalization by Yu Xin Wu and coming
her of Facebook AI research so this
paper is basically an engineering paper
about a new normalization technique
called group normalization so what's the
issue here the issue is that pretty much
throughout neural network learning we're
using this technique called batch
normalization now batch normalization is
a pretty reasonable thing and it works
very very well so what's the idea behind
batch normalization the idea is if you
have data points for machine learning
methods and your data is in a 2d
coordinate system somewhere down here
right and you're trying to separate that
from the dots which are here it is often
very beneficial to shift that
distribution before you do anything you
want to shift it to the middle of the
basically want to Center it first of all
such that the 0 the origin point is in
the middle of the data and then
sometimes you also want to do what's
called normalize it and by normalizing
we mean you want to kind of rescale the
axis such that things are more or less
sort of like gaussians so if you if you
look at this distribution first is the
centering and then second is what is
called a normalization normalization and
usually we know that any sort of machine
learning methods work better if you do
that and that's mostly in classic
machine learning methods with
conditioning numbers of the data being
better and so on but if you just want to
learn let's say a linear classifier you
can see here you can even save one
parameter because you can make it just
go through the origin and that's true in
general so if we draw this in 1d you'd
have a distribution that maybe is very
peaky right here you first center it to
the middle of the coordinate system
and sorry that's not really centered and
then you would divide it by its standard
deviation such that after it it is a
unit standard deviation Gaussian so a
normal distribution the closer your data
seems to be to a multivariate normal
distribution the better these machine
learning methods work especially if you
look at how signal in deep network is
propagating through the layers so the
idea is if it's good for the general
machine learning method that the input
has a multivariate normal distribution
or is normalized then it's probably good
that the input to each layer is
normalized so when you look at how
signal features are in between layers so
this is for example the 5/3 this is a
layer somewhere in the middle of a
convolutional neural network and if you
look at the spread of how features are
feature signals are throughout training
you'll see that the more training
progresses the larger the kind of spread
of features is so you might get really
large numbers or really large negative
numbers or maybe really small numbers in
your neural networks and it would be
better if you had a layer and the input
you've normalized it in red and the
output then is again a distribution but
it's maybe shifted that you would first
transform that back into a normal unit
normal distribution before you put it
through the next layer so what batch
norm loss is at each layer before each
layer it will do a normalization
procedure on the data before giving it
to the next layer and you can do a
basically back prop through that it's
also common to learn bias and variance
parameter to add after that but the
important thing is that after each layer
the data is normalized such that it is
kind of in the most comfortable regime
what's the problem the problem with this
is that you actually need
the distribution right if you want to
Center this data up here you need to
know what the data is so you need to
know the entire data if I want to figure
out what is the mean of this
distribution I need all of the data
points they decide here's the mean I
need to shift that up to here if I just
have a mini batch like we usually do in
machine learning so if I just have this
or this and this and this point I just
have four points I can't determine the
mean but what I can do is I can sort of
guess the mean from the four points
right so my guesstimation of the mean
would be somewhere here and that would
be usually close enough and you can also
see that the larger your batch is if you
sample at random the more accurate your
mean estimation is going to be so people
have been training neural networks with
large batch sizes for is basically batch
size I've gotten larger and larger in
the last year so that has not been a
problem but what people are doing now is
they are doing distributed machine
learning where you do have your dataset
and you draw a batch and the batch might
be large so that this might be I don't
know 1 million images this might still
be four thousand images in your batch
but what they'll do especially with
things like TP use is they'll distribute
that across many many many machines into
batches of sometimes as small as 8
samples per per unit and if if this is
not images but maybe something longer
like a sequence of text or if this is a
sequence of speech or something like
this you can sometimes even go down to
two or one samples per per unit of
computation and of course you can't do
batch normalization you can't calculate
a mean of one sample it's just going to
be that one sample itself so either you
have to you have two options if you're
in small batch sizes let's say two
either you take the hit and have your
very bad estimate of the mean from just
two samples or eight samples or after
each layer you basically
do a synchronization step such that
everyone communicates to everyone else
their statistics and you can basically
aggregate the statistics across the
batch both are not cool usually these
frameworks they don't do this
synchronization because it's just too
slow so they'll go with the bad
statistics and you can see this right
here in this graph they have the
imagenet classification error versus
batch sizes so this is a ResNet 50 model
trained on the imagenet data set using 8
workers so 8 GPUs and if they do 32
images per now just look at the blue
line here if they do 32 images per
worker so it's 8 workers it's 8 times 32
that's the batch size that is a large
number 256 maybe yeah all right so so if
they do that then you can see the error
is on a state-of-the-art for a ResNet 50
if they go to 16 it's still pretty good
but then as they go lower and lower and
lower so if they go to smaller and
smaller batches and spread them out over
the workers then the error starts going
up and this is because the batch norm
statistics get worse and worse so the
goal of this paper is to find this group
norm thing here the group norm they this
paper claims is another normalization
technique that pretty much does the same
thing this centering and the
normalization the scaling but it does it
without relying on the batch statistics
it basically does it within a data point
and that means that the performance even
though it's a bit smaller at the
beginning for this particular example
will stay constant with a even in small
batch size regime so this is potentially
applicable as I said to things where you
have to go to like two or one sample per
worker because it's just the data points
the single data points are just too
large so if you maybe
want to train something like Bert on a
on a on a GPU so what is group
normalization group normalization as I
said works within a sample now there
have been other methods that work within
a sample instead of across the batch and
they tend to not work as well as batch
norm now this paper here claims that
group norm works on par with batch norm
for large batch sizes and better than on
small batch sizes so here they have a
schematic of what's happening in batch
norm as you can see here you have this
this cube now this cube here n means the
batch size so this are the data points
points in your mini batch this is the
thing that is going to get small in the
if you don't have enough memory then C
would be your channels so we are talking
about convolutional neural networks here
but this is generalizable to other
neural networks the channels are going
to be the independent feature Maps that
you you're going to have so in a
convolutional neural network usually
each layer has these things called
kernels and there might be 3 by 3
matrices like this and the if you have
an image the kernel will be slided this
thing right here will be maybe here will
be slided across the image or slid is it
slid okay
will be slid across the image and then
the numbers in here will be convolved
with the pixels and that will give you
the next layers representation
so whatever the convolution operation is
and you slide that over and that sliding
over will give you the values in the
next layer now you not only have one
kernel but you actually have many
kernels very well let's draw that so you
have more and more kernels
[Music]
zip you have a whole stack of kernels
and how many kernels you have those are
the different kernels are also called
your different channels now the kernels
refer to the weights and the channels
refer to the image but the the if'
kernel is going to be convolving the
eyuth channel of the image so at the
beginning the input image has three
channels because red green and blue but
then the intermediate images can have
more channels as you have as basically
as many as you have kernels in the layer
right before okay and the H and the W
means the height and width of the image
so it combined so the image is kind of
unrolled across the height or the width
in this direction so what does pattern
on do batch norm takes as you can see
here one channel and it it takes one
channel so maybe this image this is one
channel let's just say this is the red
Channel because I'd drawn it in red it
takes that and it calculates the mean
one over and the standard deviation of
that it calculates those two statistics
and it uses that to do this centering
and scaling operation so all of these
methods are going to calculate the mean
and the variance and then do the same
scaling transformation the question is
just how do you calculate the mean patch
norm does this across the data points so
it looks at a single feature at a single
channel and it asks what's the mean
across all the data points what are the
data statistics of this channel and
whether it was the mean and standard
deviation now actually batch norm I'm
not I didn't even know that in
convolutional layer this works like this
you can also imagine Bachelor of really
just taking one single feature and that
means of really just taking one of these
things right here so if this goes to the
back and normalizing across that the
important part is that it is in fact
normalizing across the data points so it
looks at your batch look
at the mean and the variance in that
batch and it normalizes by that I think
convolutional layers make sense because
you have this invariance in height and
width and therefore yeah so that makes
sense but in a fully connected layer
you'd simply go you look at one feature
at a time layer norm is different layer
norm has been basically been proposed as
an alternative to batch norm with the
same reasoning that this paper has so
lave norm as you can see here it does
each data point individually so here we
only have one data point that is
normalized by itself so you do this for
each data point independently and
therefore it's not dependent on the
batch size anymore but what you'll do is
you'll look across all of the channels
right here so all of the channels and
all of the width and height so this
entire thing here this entire thing is
basically one channel right and then the
next channel is here of the image and
the next no that's the next image well
that is a bad drawing because the image
is unrolled in any case what you'll do
is you'll look at so if you have a
filter Bank like this you have an image
and the image composed of multiple
channels right this is the red and then
you have the green right this is in the
green and then you'll have the blue
Channel and what you'll do is simply you
calculate the mean across all of the
pixels and across all of the channels
you just take this whole numpy array and
you just say dot mean and that gives you
one number and it's just whatever that
number is you subtract it and then you
say standard deviation and you divide by
that that's layer norm so an entire
layers representation of one image is
just normalized to the mean now this
seems a bit drastic
and that's why instance norm did the
exact opposite they said wait a minute
instead of normalizing across
all of the features right we'll go back
and do what batch norm does batch norm
looks at each feature individually so
basically it looks as all of these these
different axes in the data distribution
it looks at them differently so if one
axis is scaled very widely we want to
normalize that differently than if then
the other axis that is just scaled very
shortly and that's why we'll look at
each feature individually like batch
norm but also we only look at one data
point at a time now as you can imagine
this doesn't work anymore in in a fully
connected Network this basically works
in a convolutional Network where you
have a feature map channel so you look
at one individual Channel and one data
point so that means here you would
normalize the red channel individually
you would normalize the green Channel
individually and you'd normal normalize
the blue Channel individually so the
image you're gonna end up with is simply
the red Channel subtracted by its own
mean and then divided by its own
standard deviation and just within that
data point right so maybe I should here
say across the number of features or
something so I hope that that's clear so
the layer norm drops the dependence on
the batch size but instead says we
should normalize across all of the
features and the instance norm says wait
a minute batch norm had a good idea
normalizing only across the features
individually because the individual
features might have different scales and
we should account for that but also we
don't want to be dependent on the batch
size and now is this where group norm
comes in group norm is basically a mix
between layer norm and instance norm
what group norm says let your norm and
instance norm have good ideas they only
go across one sample they take that they
say in essence instance norm has a good
idea in that the features should be
normalized individually but it goes sort
of too far from
it goes too far you might get not good
enough statistics because you're now
normalizing each of these things
individually
whereas with layer' norm you're too
restricted you're basically saying that
the features it's fine if the feature is
relative to each other or like this
right one is might be very high variance
and one is very low variance feature
norm would keep that and group norm
would say maybe that's not it's not so
good we should have we should normalize
the individual features maybe
individually but they'll they're
argumentation here is that maybe there
are some features that by their nature
already have the same sort of scaling
and variance they give an example if you
for example have a filter again we deal
with convolutional layers here and that
filter is a let's say an edge filter
right so a horizontal edge filter so
it's very low value here and let me mark
the high value with blue so this is a
horizontal edge filter if you slide this
over a window and these are high numbers
and these are low numbers it will
respond to edges because edges have high
low high right or vice versa
so it will give you very positive and
very negative number every time you
slide across an edge now you can imagine
that in natural images that filter
whatever image you put in would and
however you normalize would give you
pretty much the same response as a
vertical edge filter so the horizontal
and the vertical edge filter you you see
whatever their response is they're
probably about equal in size so we could
expect that in a neural network there
will be groups of filters that together
exhibit the same scale and therefore we
can normalize across them like in layer
norm the so the more things we normalize
across the better statistics we can
gather that's why instance norm doesn't
work because it only normalized across a
very small thing getting very little
statistics
we should normalize if we could gather
good statistics we should normalize
different features differently then
group norm says well since some of the
features are almost guaranteed to behave
the same
we couldn't normalize across those now
of course you don't know at the
beginning which ones those are so but
you you hope that by doing group norm by
basically at a priori so at the
beginning of training you decide what
the groups aren't and naturally it's
just whichever ones are next to each
other those are the groups and you'll
hope that through the training procedure
basically those groups will learn the
features that are equal of size well you
basically enforce that so you kind of
constrain the architecture to do that so
that's the idea behind group norm you
basically build these groups of channels
and then you normalize across those
across the groups of within the groups
of channels across the entire height and
width only in a single data point and
therefore you gain the advantage of
layer norm of normalizing within a
single data point you retain the
advantage of batch norm of of
normalizing across single features and
that's what instance norma tempted but
yeah so you get the best of both worlds
sort of that's group norm and now we go
and look what it does so they say okay
basically all the normalization
techniques do this they subtract the
mean and divide by a standard deviation
that's what we saw and the difference is
just across what you collect your
statistics so the group norm is the
following code in tensor flow as you can
see you simply reshape your data and
basically expand this part right here
where you build you where you put the
extra so this is C this entire thing
used to be C and you divide it into
group and index within group and then
you just normalize across that and
reshape to the original demand
again and the important the cool thing
is in batch norm you have to keep track
of these of these running means because
at test time you sort of don't want the
batch statistic to influence anything
you don't have that here you can just
back propagate through this observation
through this operation and you don't
need to keep these running running
averages going and you always care are
am I in test or am i in train mode right
now you just do this this operation is
per data point so it's just part of your
model right and they do a an experiment
where they have 32 images per GPU so
it's reasonably sized and they can
basically show that the group norm and
the batch norm they compare in their
performance now I usually don't believe
the experiments that you see in single
papers but I think this has been
replicated a couple of times now you see
this is the Train error where a group
norm even behaves a bit better and then
in the validation error it behaves a bit
worse but one could say it is it is kind
of more closely together than the other
methods are to the group norm or to each
other these instants norm and layer norm
so it at least it's better than instance
norm and layer norm and then once you go
into the smaller batch size regime of
course that's where the group norm
starts to shine so if you go from the 32
images per GPU which is this low black
curve here all the way to two images per
GPU and I believe they think they could
even do one image per GPU with group
norm but of course you can't do that
with batch norm because you need batch
statistics you can see that the the
performance of batch norm degrades
drastically
whereas with group norm an if this
experiment is just funny they just have
to do this even though you know exactly
what turns out so look at the lines are
all exactly in the in the same place I
mean come on like now you know you're
just having time to
probably one of the reviewers was like
what did you really do the experiment to
put it so yeah so you can see that the
the batch norm beats the group norm in
this setting with the when you have the
larger batch sizes but the group norm
pulls ahead quite drastically when you
have the smaller batch sizes and that is
the main advantage so now you can turn
to models that require small batch sizes
or a small batch per worker and
generally it's a pain in the ass to just
keep track of those statistics for test
time they do verify which I find pretty
cool that this phenomenon of the
response is going apart during training
in the internal feature Maps a bachelor
room counteracts that so with batch norm
you'll get actually a convergence of
responses during training so the more
you train the more normalized basically
your internal features will be and they
show that this is exactly the same with
group norms so group norm is as it seems
it is a replacement it's not an addition
it doesn't the gains don't come from
different place it seems to be a
substitute for a batch norm though they
don't have an experiment where they do
both I believe maybe I'm wrong actually
maybe they do but yeah it seems like you
just kind of have to bring some calmness
on some standardization into your signal
and how exactly you do that doesn't seem
that important as long as you do it with
some precision and some some real
overall statistics yeah what I don't
like about this is now you have of
course a new hyper parameter which is
this number of groups right so that that
seems rather annoying and the gains like
this usually come from the introductions
of new hyper parameters and and that
just it's not so it's not that ideal for
a method to introduce a new hyper
at least lair norm and instance norm
didn't and now as you can see the number
of groups is is not super influential
but does have a bit of an influence on
the on the performance so if you go a
number of groups or here a number of
channels per group of course these two
numbers are inversely related to the
more groups you have the less number of
channels per group we have if you go to
one extreme you will get to the lair
norm basically so the lair norm is an
extreme case of group norm where you
just have one group all the channels are
in the same group then the performance
as you can see here is quite a bit worse
if you go to the other extreme where
every channel is its own group that's
equivalent to instance norm again the
performance is quite bad and somewhere
in the middle here with 32 groups is
seems to be a good sweet spot so I don't
again i don't like the hyper parameter
seems to be some somewhat of a thing
where you really have to hit a good
value and well I guess we'll see over
time if that value is always going to be
about the same you know like the beta 2
of atom it's it's always like people
never change it from 0.999 because it
just tends to work or whether that's
really going to be another hyper
parameter to fit that seems to be
annoying they do a bunch of ablation
studies and tests on as we said the for
example object detection and
segmentation so so models where you must
go almost to small batch sizes just
because so video classification so if
you want to classify an entire video
that's a lot of data right and you
almost have to go small batch sizes for
that they do a lot of experiments and
generally as I said I believe these
results in for group norm have been
replicated and across the community a
bunch of times now and I would
definitely consider group norm if you
are thinking of a especially a
distributed machine learner
project alright with that I hope you
enjoyed this paper I've been talking for
way too long now I wish you and I stay
if you haven't already please subscribe
like share comment or whatever you feel
like doing
bye bye